what's up everyone this is Anthony popli
I know most of you know me as pump
you're listening to off the chains
simply the best podcasting crypto let's
kick this thing off
wrong Chen is the founder of Alaska's in
this conversation we discussed working
at Microsoft in the early days building
network operating systems why the
decentralized internet is important how
alas toes is pushing the pace of
innovation and we're wrong things gaps
may have gone wrong I really enjoyed
this conversation and I hope you do as
well
sitting here with wrong supersite have
this conversation
there's a lot of people excited we're
gonna talk today so thanks so much for
coming to do this well thank you so much
for sure let's jump right in what uh
what's your background kind of pre free
Bitcoin cryptocurrency blockchain would
you do before my background is I came to
this country I came to New York
January 4th of 1984 that's when the
internet named internet from a Burnett
and also that's when UNIX open source to
universities so I went for the
University of Illinois to study
operating systems and ever since it's
been 35 years in 1984 you had to go
study operating systems yes had that's
pretty good foresight oh it's a fluke
cuz I look back at that time I thought
we were just studying you know come to
this country with more advanced computer
science research but on the other hand I
overlooked that was actually the year if
you look at Microsoft Oracle Sam
mackerel and Apple actually all founders
were born in 55 really right all right
so you're just saying that's a
generation of innovation it's just born
at the right time I would put it this
way reborn in 55 57 so hi little but
they're not too far that sort of thing
at that time what I overlooked to us
we're saying okay everything is a given
should be naturally that's what we
daddy instead of seeing that's a great
opportunity I didn't see that part yep
to this day I still regret I see and so
what did you do after school then I went
to Microsoft Research what was that
that's a 92 doing operating systems and
later on I moved down to Internet
Explorer which is the browser I was a
tenth employee of Microsoft ie and from
there we moved down naturally going to
design down that what was Microsoft
Research like what was that culture like
well it's a very open at that time 92
was very very small cuz I actually Xerox
PARC IBM dr. heights and AT&T Bell Labs
or the better known ones and no one
really wanna go to Microsoft to do
research at that point but I ended up
there just also by some accidents
because of I was from China I couldn't
be hired by IBM AT&T or Xerox PARC so
because it was a communist country right
and so Microsoft was my only not chosen
choice but looking back I was really
really fortunate for sure you catch the
wave of the whole you know Windows
Internet everything for sure you ever
hang out with the Bill Gates or Steve
Ballmer Matt a few times what what do
they like well they're sick bombers way
nice guy actually he's a nice guy he is
and Bill Gates nice to the employees but
kind of mean to executives so he was
nice to the employees but mean to the
executives and any any funny stories
that you have well you know at that time
because Microsoft was small and all new
hires got a chance to eat dinner at Bill
Gates house Wow at that time and so I
remember I went right cuz
reason I went is because I wouldn't see
he was the richest guy in the world
already at that time ninety-two and so I
was the fascinating you know we're just
okay go to the richest guys are home
have a dinner and was very very moderate
and the very first question you know our
co new hires asked so asking bill was is
it really your home so he was a richest
guy in the world in 1992 and you guys go
to his house and no one believed it was
his house because hardly any footage her
Wow and also it's odd house yeah that's
awesome but he but like I think that's
part of the beauty of him right the
warren buffett's of the world etc is
that they don't care about the material
things right and also I also appreciate
you know his mother did so much for
United Way and we follow suits and we
helped it contribute to the to the cost
that's awesome alright so at some point
you moved to China and you lived there
for what last like 20 years or so yeah I
returned back to China in year 2000
after we designed we started the project
caught on that which I'll mention
because that meaning work in the design
a operating system for the network
instead of designing a operating system
for the computer for a device right
which is really my passion because I
believe that's the real solution to
solve the internet virus issues a DDoS
attack issues or the piracy issues but
unfortunately you know we started we
have that dream 99 which is literally
twenty years ago and which and to today
it's still not being accepted by the
community for sure where where'd you
live in China I live in Shanghai and
sure you know what's that like right now
wow it's a foot past 20 years has
improved so much it's a it's it's a very
modern much part in now
yeah with all the neon lights and stuff
it and I've never been but the photos
I've seen it kind of looks a little bit
like Las Vegas or like Times Square yeah
yeah I may be more lights yeah
absolutely and so what what's the UM the
current situation I'm like the
geopolitical front right so you've got I
think here in the West most people are
educated by the mainstream media the
mainstream media has a very kind of
specific perspective of China both at
the technology industry but also kind of
the political stuff that's going on sure
you lived there you were on the ground
like what was your general take in terms
of how did the citizens interact with
the government and then how does
technology companies and engineers play
into all that well the Chinese employees
right engineers they worked really
extremely hard because of they have this
mentality you know because for the
thirty years ago was a radically poor
country and open up and if you see what
what it has today it's catching up
really really fast because so far the
engineers working they call it nine nine
six nine nine six so yeah basically they
work from 9:00 to 9:00 for six days a
week
Wow that's what it is right nine to nine
six days a week that's yeah yeah yeah a
lot of companies require or yeah most of
the employees work that hard it is um
there's a gentleman in Silicon Valley
I'm gonna forget who who wrote it but
they wrote a op-ed here in America and
they basically were pretty blatantly
saying that China is out working in the
United States right by working hours yes
and and they were talking about this
idea of one the amount of work right in
terms of the hours - a lot of people
were actually living in like kind of
company sponsored facilities right so
almost like dorm rooms if you will
especially the younger engineers and
things like that and they were basically
just talking about like you know America
can't get comfortable right and and if
you want innovation there starts to be
hard work involved with it
and if you go and you look at other
places in the world they may not have
the same perspective we do in terms of
work-life balance seeing all these kind
of things that are popular in the US now
that's not necessary popular everywhere
in the world and it leads to very
different kind of work cultures yeah I
believe in the way that saying it's true
because of for the first generation and
like me being first-generation
immigrants we work harder than most of
the native-born
right but let's say even in China the
second generation especially the
one-child policy the kids tend to be
more spoiled so I'm not sure if this
kind of mentality will last for the time
being right that's the case got it and
so right now it's true but demographics
can change and dance can can definitely
evolve but but it's interesting to think
through and then what is the kind of the
whole blockchain in China situation
right because it seems like that changes
quite often right actually I was
surprised on the October 24th and
actually made an announcement on 25th
that you know the government will go
full-throttle blockchain which is little
surprised everyone but looking at it
it's not quite out of the blue because
of there's a saying right you know China
is a big government instead of aiming a
smaller government in the United States
a bar big garland meaning it has a lot
of power resources and absolute power
implies absolute corruption which is
true everywhere in the way the Chinese
employees or the government are not very
efficient because even for government
officials they work Saturdays you call
the map they come to have business
meetings really right so they don't
really take weekend off but on the other
hand even the power there indeed some
corruptions a red tape and everywhere
because of let's say a lot of so many
so-called stay on
the prices not just necessarily
government per se but let's say a
state-owned enterprise has to be real
power grid you know those companies are
huge like a million employees two
million employees Wow and also if the
CEO cannot fire the the county level
let's say a power supplier then where's
those efficiency or where you know
there's a corruption because of they can
turn off your power you know asking
before no bribing state sanctioned
mafias so then you can see if they do
have blockchain and keep track of
prominence and recording of the
documents then I do believe that a
streamline a lot of those red tapes got
it and it sounds like they're not only
interested in just crypto currencies but
also in blockchain for a whole bunch of
different applications but the one here
in the US has really I think caught
people's attention is this dcep right
the digital currency well yeah that's
their digital currency and you liked on
your payment if you've been to China for
a leap a ten cent pay that we check pay
right uh almost everywhere and and
there's people use their mobile phones
to pay right basically when I was a when
we're in China it's a cashless society
now basically anywhere you don't you
don't need to bring your wallet you just
burn your phone that's all there is to
it amazing yeah very very efficient you
pay peer-to-peer you pay all the vendors
so given that that's the the case right
and the Garmin asks the electronic
payments to replace the the paper bills
then they're promoting something like in
the airplane where there's no Wi-Fi
signal no mobile signal you can still
shake your phone and pay peer-to-peer
with airdrop your your virtual money
yeah right so then basically they don't
promote
are cryptos they promote something you
trust me you trust the state-owned banks
to have consortium chains then we're
issuing they're issuing those crypto
currency right to replace the not really
replace to kind of like augment
arguments or the the ally pay on and we
JP so i buy that it's way more efficient
right i buy that it can really help the
user experience etc i think that the
downside though is it could increase
like the surveillance and and the
ability for whether it's the government
or private enterprises to see what
citizens are doing is that part of the
conversation in china not necessarily
has there anything to do with Kryptos if
you've been to China you see some runs
cameras almost it's pretty crazy pretty
crazy
yeah but then that's really uh it's a
different issue it's not related to the
blockchains yeah it when in part of my
question is really is that part of the
conversation right like do citizens
realize that or our most citizens just
this is what I grew up and this is all I
know and so it's not well of course uh
all the citizens we're all for you if
you just open your eyes yeah cameras
so then Asian culture is a somewhat
different from the Western culture
because of if you go to Japan you go to
Korea go to China they're all tends to
be overcrowded historically for
thousands of years and so then kind of
the live on the religious they have a
commune you know one helping the other
more like
group they have sense of group instead
of more individualism you know like
being a one-person like last blood you
know who can one person Rambo could save
the world that's kind of a different
mentality for sure as you think about
this you eventually moved on and started
alas dose what was the first time you
ever saw blockchain or Bitcoin or crypto
like how did you initially get
interested in it well actually I started
I went back to China started this
network of OS as I said I quit Microsoft
for one single simple reason because
Microsoft at that time decided to do a
networked OS which I foo heartedly
believe and but on the other hand at
that time they wanna do it in c-sharp
like a Java equivalent intermediate
language which I don't believe I wanted
to be more fundamental I want to do it
in native CPU instructions so then
because it's a different level of
abstraction I believe computer science
has to go down to the metal go down to
the CPU level that was the reason I went
back to set up my own operating system
venture and trying to design a Naruko OS
and one thing lead to another by 2012 I
got some investment from fast comm which
is up from Foxconn vodka which is one of
the biggest companies in the world right
they make 100 percent of the iPhones
assembly blue-collar workers assemble
all the iPhones iPads and also like a
Kindle e-books and stuff Foxconn does a
lot of research as well even though it's
over shadowed by the workers so at that
time I got some funding from them doing
the industrial ilt doing the smart home
OS so then we can make smart homes safer
and protect
the encryption protect the privacy all
for citizens right or the users but in
around and of 2016-2017
we ran into some issues so I have to
find alternative investments there I
found botching because of for two things
one is because of the e theorem at that
point and also Bitcoin price went up
like crazy everyone learned the term and
also people start to raise funds using
those Kryptos so when I was looking for
funding definitely that's something
caught my eye and when I study those
crypto projects right and especially a
lot of those so-called smart
contract-based
block team projects that talked about
the apps they talk about ecosystems and
then and also when I researched on
YouTube and what is interim in one
sentence and the founder of e term
saying that's a warped computer right so
those term jargons caught my eye because
of what's a computer I've been doing
computers all my life and we started
from paper tapes a core memory back in
China so which is really really the
fundamental owed machine and we've been
doing ecosystems as trained Microsoft
operating system designer or architect
because when you talk about enjoy when
you talk about iPhone what do you say
you don't basically they build
ecosystems right they build apps so then
I would study more about what is a work
computer what is a tab what is a
ecosystem then I realized the blockchain
world well they are they are very
innovative innovative but on the other
hand there are lacking of some
the mentors because of they're not
trained to be the designer of a computer
or a ecosystem so that's where I find we
have a chance got it and so what is the
lastest today alas those just by name of
it right
Elastic Compute elastic laugh when
computer actually I named it in 2002
okay and Amazon came up coincidentally
Elastic Compute 2006 got it what is
Elastic Compute you lastly compute
meaning in virtual machines all over
instead of physical machines basically
you Sporn
you you create virtual machines on
demand instead of because making a hard
a hard work computer they take the
resources takes time but if you make
virtual computers on demand which is
setting up us in a completely different
level right and so you last was
according because we've been working on
this virtual machine for us since 2002
we've been working on this smart home
network since 2012 and all we need is
another really key piece of puzzle
missing which is the blockchain give us
the decentralized IDs give us the
decentralized everything so then we can
build a decentralized web and so alas
dose is literally elastic OS kind of
putting those two words together yeah
got it and so when you get started what
was kind of the original idea in terms
of what you could build was it one
single product was it to go after the
whole ecosystem like how did you think
about it at that time we were going
after the network computer that but in
year 2000 network meaning the local
network let's say you have a room of 100
employees with 100 pcs can you manage
them as a as a whole like if you look at
the autonomous driving in a Missy Missy
DS Bank vehicle model
vehicle there about a hundred CPUs
billion right can you imagine the other
100 C computers or are they just a
single computer on four wheels so that's
different perspective and the one
computer perspective I have a better
control over the controlling security
controlling the wearer's issues yeah
that's when we started got it and so
when you get started one of the things
I've heard you talk about in the past
is this idea of like a smart web right
maybe talk us through how you define
smart web and how that differs from that
ww-well no and a lot of people in the
blockchain world talk about that value
internet saying the old internet is the
information internet I think there's a
guy caught it down Tapscott who gave a
TED talk right he summoned it up as the
old internet everything you share is a
copy you share on Facebook a photo
that's a copy of the photo and the value
internet if I gave you a Bitcoin then I
don't have it anymore
so that's a has a scarcity which is the
value and then but then on the other
hand the community is short from saying
if you give me a token usually for a
trade for goods and currently the goods
you trade are offline goods can you
trade online virtual digital assets
right people are talking about a
building a virtual economy so then you
can trade protect user data and trade
user data but trade user data that's
where we come in if I give you a user
data
the last Internet giving you a copy
which a lot of Perak see and doesn't
have much value even though you can keep
the prominence you can record this
barcode or digital signature of the
file on a blockchain but you cannot
protect the para sea or virus then
really you still don't have much value
for the digital assets to send a digital
asset you have to send code you cannot
just send a file being played by media
player right so if you sign a binary
code over the binary runs and validated
itself and checked blockchain do you
still own it let's say if I send you a
binary code which is my encrypted my
personal data right I send it to you and
if I sewed it to you you run it I still
have a copy on my hard drive if I run it
and I say okay Ron you don't have the
right anymore right so that's where when
you share a value value internet really
your sharing code when you have the
information internet right that's
www-where you run sharing code we call
it a smart web smartphone meaning the
phone that runs apps the internet runs
taps are the smart rap got it and so
that smart web talk to me about
is it decentralized is it not
decentralized like how how do you think
about building it Rea because you
describe what the functionality of it is
but but how do you think about actually
building something like that we are
actually I'm glad you asked we're really
really close because we're going through
we have pretty much got everything build
the last big missing piece it would be
the browser and the website the browser
will be released first week of January
so basically in three weeks we're going
to release the browser basically
reminded me of 193 when the mosaic
browser was released more recent Marc
Andreessen that's January of 93
throughout 93 basically the University
of Illinois a set up the
the daba daba daba web at that point so
we're really really close from shipping
the smart web browser but but in before
we get to the browser there's kind of
three levels as I understand in terms of
the the stack of what you guys have
rattled going after this idea of the
smart web allows you to send value or
code rather than the information web or
WIBW what are those three kind of layers
if you will to what you guys have
already bilks I think that framework at
least it helps me understand better as
to you know why you think the smart web
so important the fundamental layer we do
like a Yahweh token that's the token we
issued merge mine with Bitcoin meaning
the Bitcoin miners when they update the
software from bit main actually they
could merge mine basically you don't
spend extra power you learn you you you
you mine
both Yahweh and BTC okay so explain this
concept I don't think a lot of people's
before merge mining is I'm a minor
I bought some hardware from Maine or
whoever I plug in my equipment I get the
internet hooked up I get it ready to go
I start mining Bitcoin right where do
you come into that how do i basically
configure that software because it's a
the future the latest feature is built
in now okay so then you turn it on then
you can get a X for some tokens got it
any my when I'm mining on the Bitcoin
blockchain I'm validating those
transactions and I'm securing the
Bitcoin network what am i doing on on
your end there's a set product you'll
also a secure the yelly maintained and
or so mining the eoa tokens at the same
time right currently there are about
more than 50% of the Bitcoin miners also
mine yowee tokens
oh really yeah which make us the third
most powerful main chain in the world
the hash power wise and in that hash
power is approximately 50% of Bitcoin
miners are discovering and validating
the BIC
chain but they're also doing yours as
well yeah when we step in into your
office we just checked I was a 52% 52%
Wow
I didn't know that it's very big number
actually it is a big big number so the
reason why we have that maintained is
because everyone believed in Bitcoin and
it's not being controlled and given that
main chain you know we merge my with
Bitcoin so we we gain the trust right of
course
high confidence no one I mean I wouldn't
say no one why are we very hard well and
what I think you guys have done here and
correct me if I'm wrong is you've
essentially said bitcoins miners make it
incredibly secure and make it incredibly
decentralized right in nature and so if
we are able to incentivize or kind of go
along with those same miners then we'll
be secure and we'll be decentralized as
well and so you're kind of rooting the
decentralization and security of your
blockchain in with the the folks that
are mining and validating the Bitcoin
right and also we give the Bitcoin
miners a higher calling because they are
helping us to secure the new Internet
right so new internet what's the value
of a new Internet of course if you look
at the Oh WWE tablet web there's no IDs
so everyone could fake everyone else or
impersonate or being a dog you don't
know so given the DeSantis ID so on top
of this main chain we're building these
Angeles IDs currently the alas those
decentralized ID is w3c compliant and so
given those IDs and also giving the main
chain so we can encrypt messages
peer-to-peer well okay so on so you got
to merge my name with Bitcoin right
that's kind of that foundational layer
then a second layer on top of that is
this idea of a decentralized internet
correct right and internet involves
identity and a whole bunch of other
things but the idea is you've got a
blockchain that blockchain is super
secure it is decentralized because
you're basically
riding along with bitcoins blockchain in
terms of using their their miners to
help you you built a decentralized
internet on top of that and there's a
third layer which is more around kind of
governance and consensus right the
second tier is actually it's a
peer-to-peer network okay
it's very much like a FaceTime or Skype
or BT BitTorrent or Napster to start it
but all the old peer-to-peer network
they have a central website mm-hmm right
so they are liable or they're
controlling then can we make those
central website being decentralized
routed back inversely to the blockchain
right they used to have a governing
website now the its kind of put it the
other way around blockchain is what the
blockchain is the the backside so it's
not controlled by Apple or Microsoft got
it and there's another notion from Danny
to saying the network is the computer
from the inventor of Java programming
language I was a long time ago right and
as I said Microsoft on that was trying
to do a operating system for the
networked computer and the second year
of our so-called care network or
peer-to-peer decentralized peer-to-peer
network is literally building this new
smart web computer and to have this
computer is decentralized but yet on top
of it there are users we hope to have
billions of users right and and also for
this design choice computer we need
administrators right this uh let's say
decentralized exchange who should be
listed or when we have a new smart
contracts or new governor's model
algorithm should we kick that in so it's
more like the first abandonment or
second amendment
you know those communities should we are
run this let's say currently we have a
4% inflation every two minutes we have
five more tokens are mined right
is that a good number for person is that
too high too low should you know the
community make a deep learning algorithm
to adjust the inflation rate so
definitely those are governed by smart
contracts or programs okay and the
administrator the consensus decides to
kick that in right that's the
administrator of this smart web computer
of this work and who access the
administrator currently we are going to
kick off this election also by the first
week by the end of this year or by the
first week of January there's there are
12 seats so anybody is welcome to run of
course you have to get the vote from the
community right and 2/3 of the council
members and vote will decide on whether
we kick in another smart contracts to
run this community got it and one of the
things that I think you've talked a lot
about is you've got this merge mining
you've got this decentralized internet
and then you've got kind of cyber
Republic governance but the
decentralized internet services right
that this idea of flipping
decentralization you know in the crypto
community I think a lot of people talk
about these DAPs right these
decentralized applications and you know
that they run around and they say I've
got a decentralized application and I
always joke that Jeff Bezos controls the
entire decentralized application market
because that everyone's building the top
AWS correct
so how decentralized can it actually be
if you're just building a top of AWS
basically in my opinion a app first of
all let's go back to the App 84 when I
first came to this country at that point
UNIX open sourced right barely long time
ago 35 years ago and at that time there
was no distinction between system
developer and the app developer because
in 84 there's no literally almost no
applications like tcp/ip is running in
the user mode of UNIX or Linux for that
matter
right but it's not really a application
in consumers minds today because in
consumers minds
whatever runs on Android phone on iPhone
that's an app tcp/ip is part of the
system
but UNIX or Linux doesn't really
distinguish whether you are a system
programmer versus application programmer
kind of interwined
midst so that's why we see lot of Eris's
because application pretend to be the
system and you're taking advantage of
the loopholes and shortcomings then they
no still user data right then if we're
saying alas those computers we build
virtual machine so that's another layer
the virtual machine runs apps apps runs
inside virtual machine below Virtual
Machine above kernel that's quite a
system software which does not exist 35
years ago ok
but today which is so obvious right and
if you look at a lot of proc team
projects they're basically still using
the old web using the older Linux
because they just do the recording of
the hash on a smart contract or on a
blockchain but on the other hand it's
also or the lot programming logic is
running on the website if Amazon shuts
the website down or some virus attacked
her like Adi dyn.com right or the
Adina's resolution attack then the whole
internet got broken and everything shuts
down so if any app that can be
manipulated by a third party shuts down
the website which is not app because
you've sent $10,000 on a kitty but then
if the websites are run out of business
then the kitty is not running anymore so
basically there's failure points right
there's this idea that the website is a
centralized point of failure
that if somebody's able to shut down
that website you don't have the portal
into current centralized water and
therefore this problem right so then in
that sense it's not the dab can still be
manipulated can still be shut down right
even though the smart contracts cannot
be shut down but the app the dab can be
shut down yep and so then that's the
when I study the the dabs of the
ecosystem or the work computer that's
actually I realize that's a big big
loophole so we need to fix so that's
where the alas was coming in and
building the care network and without
letting currently like the first years
of Bitcoin miners the second tier
actually is a deep-ass machines the deep
house right if I you rent a machine in
Amazon Cloud in Alibaba clouds Microsoft
Azure clouds you were they you're there
just for a simple reason for rewards and
you run a virtual machine you don't even
know what's running in the virtual
machine on the doctor right so those are
the actually waiting for tasks waiting
for jobs the job could be hosting a web
service of a website and so then the
programmer of the website cannot control
the machine which runs the website
because if you see today's website it's
written and operated by the same party
then the wife's eyes should be written
by one party and operated by different
parties what's the downside of that so I
see the the upside or the advantage
right what's the downside I don't really
see a downside that's really a great
step forward mmm because of what we
really should separate them mm-hmm and
and really what this does is it adds
this sense of decentralization so that
you don't have the same parties
controlling the entire stack how the
vertical integration of the services now
you get more of a fragmented approach in
this decentralized internet services
there any loss of efficiencies or
anything like that or you you feel like
everything it still kind of works how
it's supposed to work it should work out
as opposed to work a little bit because
of if you have website right of course
it's a little bit more efficient but
given the current internet given the
fiber optics in and out of homes given
the virtual machines because virtual
machine itself lose some performance
from the naked horror but then given the
the current state of art the hardware
right because humans don't evolve that
fast we can watch a movie you know 50 60
frames or 30 frames per second and 60
frames giving you a very smooth feeling
but after 50 frames you don't really
feel anymore but the computers evolve so
then given the current state of art
Hardware the virtual machine layer lost
some performance let's say 10 percent 20
percent it's acceptable and also the
other side to put it as if the websites
without a fixed IP addresses it's very
hard to for the DNS resolution attack
for the middleman attack more spriting
viruses all those issues are gone right
in return you know lost some performance
but gain so much yeah and so if I'm a
developer and I want to go build in this
ecosystem or build these truly
decentralized applications I really have
to think about you know what's the
application I'm building how do I
prevent there being a centralized
website how do I actually look at what
cloud or hardware I'm using on the
server side like there's a lot of
different levels of complexity and kind
of nuance here how are people learning
about this makes it feels like most
engineers grew up in a world where
everything was centralized that's how
they were taught where do you see that
education happening and how are people
kind of learning about building in this
in this new decentralized world well a
lot of people because of as I said UNIX
was from like early 80s and basically
the most a lot of young programmers they
born
without seeing something different the
windows and unit Linux right for the
whole life whole young life and so first
of all the hard part is a change of
mentality to be more open-minded but on
the other hand given my background
because of right now
in those years 1980s the tcp/ip and
operators over there are interwined so
if you look at today all the internet
gaming all those applications who deal
with internet they have to application
programmers have to deal with internet
themselves to open up a socket and to
send network packets and also if you're
a consumer lost their password
you know they blame on the users right
saying okay why don't you pick a select
a stronger password so that's uh if
we're separating applications from the
network if we're separating using the D
ID and keep track of the digital
signatures and the user on their own
data
they don't have to remember their
password anymore and the developers
doesn't have to deal with Network
anymore the programming would be much
much easier to write because they don't
really have to think of those so-called
transactions or internet timing issues
those ones are handled by the system and
so as you think through this what's the
end goal like okay everything that
you're saying ends up getting built it
works where do we end up what is that
like final stage look like uh I hope
summer it up in two ways okay
technically speaking now because people
are saying IT industry evolves so fast
for the past 70 years and finally we're
at the stage the IT industry in terms of
what's network what's programming model
what's an operating system we're
maturing
finally and we named it e last O's elast
OS meaning there's no more literally if
you look at we're not really bragging
because if you look at the windows
Windows 10 no more windows 11 that's
according to Microsoft no more windows
11 meanings Windows 10 forever when we
do name when I name it he last oh as in
2002 we kind of anticipated no more new
operating systems because this is an
operating system for the network how can
I force the the peripherals let's say
the TV screen in your room to update the
device driver when I came in because the
next speaker should you download that
the the device driver if you have web
services all over the world how can you
force those web services to upgrade or
downgrade according to your OS if you
don't if you are the ecosystem right and
people species live and die there's no
single point we upgrade of a machine
right of the network you upgrade machine
but you don't upgrade the whole network
so that's why when we design a network
OS it has to be the network of forever
right that's technically for the
consumers when we finally could have
this kind of trading peer-to-peer token
for good and that's a new economy
because the old web everything's owned
by cartels all the books all the movies
I mean God forbid if Amazon
out of business all my ebooks right are
gone it's not like the old books I can
put on my bookshelf I owned them I can
give it to friends but my ebooks I
cannot give it or resell it if we could
have this peer-to-peer trading of
digital assets that's kind of a
private ownership or capitalism for the
first time on the Internet that's huge
for sure
how does identity play into this right
you you you've mentioned a couple of
times it's like decentralized web and
identity where does that plan
well decentralized ah because on this
new Internet we need to have some sort
of identity because I know when I am
chatting who I'm chatting with does it
have to be my real identity nope because
uh that's another thing if you look at
it today I just mentioned the passwords
if you look at your driver's license it
has a driver license number it all has
your birthday it has your gender has a
lot of more information but which is
again not enough if you want to travel
abroad you need a passport or if you
want to go to hospital it needs some
more a different set of IDs and in some
cases you want to anonymous sometimes
you want to be real name so then a ID
meaning just a cryptic hash write 256 in
inland the digit then even that you have
multiple profiles okay and then so you
want to sign in with your real name
profile or you want to sign in we or
your alias or you wanna then it's up to
you but nevertheless you sign with your
your private keys if you sign you gave
information let's say if you login to
Facebook or some other apps you log in
with Facebook ID credential then I'm
again what I'm saying is in theory
Facebook could impersonate you mm-hmm
right maybe they don't but then they
could they saying okay you're trusting
Facebook your ties this book company to
use your credentials only when you said
use my credentials for web sites that
you've said it but at any point they
could go in to login to the other apps
which use a facebook login you
correct and but for the D ID just given
the number given your gender your name
to Facebook the Facebook still does not
have your private key so it cannot
impersonate you to log into some other
websites got it and so what you're
talking about is I create an identity
and that identity has almost multiple
layers to it so I want to act anonymous
I want to act suit anonymous
pseudonymity for multiple you know
services or various verticals then I've
got my real identity with minimal
information shared I've got my real
identity you know with a lot of
information shared and then I've got
kind of full-blown here's everything I
got that's real
all of those different types of
identities play into various aspects of
my life or services I user but I'm in
control of choosing which one I yes
because if I if you tell me your name
right hmm I'll validate through your
pocket key which is topic information
and no you are the only one you could
sign it off mm-hmm so that's really
really critical to this new Internet
yeah and and some of this too is that
there's a lot of encrypted I think where
people are trying to solve some of these
problems around you know what these
episodes uses these like zero knowledge
proof right this whole idea of if you go
into a bar and I show you my ID all you
need to know is am I 21 or not you don't
even need to know how old I am right but
instead I just showed you my name my
address you know all these different
things well in the future there will be
some way to just say thumbs up yes 21 or
over thumbs down no that is very
simplistic right in terms of how
identification is used in a scenario but
that same type of mechanism applies
almost every single time you use ID
right how many times do you go somewhere
and people say you know show me your
driver's license sure but it's not for
driving they just want to know that's
really you write a photo and a name and
what cracks me up is if you've ever gone
to the airport or the bank or anything
and they say show it to me if you have a
photo where you know you had a shaved
head and now you have hair
or you you know you used to have a beard
and now you don't the person doesn't
know right they're just they're just
happy as someone has an ID that kind of
sort of looks like the person and they
approve it which probably isn't the most
secure thing to to do right yeah yeah
but ideas only Larry there's only one
part of the story right cuz uh that's
why we build this new smart web it's not
just the ID but also given your ID given
the the wallet given the the the
capability to run those virtual machines
so you can conduct business you can do
something mm-hmm right how long give us
kind of a status update of how things
are going right so so we understand how
it works now any milestones or data that
you can share in terms of how it's going
yeah so far this project has been around
two-and-a-half years we started in
August with 2017 and we started to we
started the main chain in December of
2017 and then August of 2018 we started
merge mining and also we implemented the
first versions of the ID currently we're
trying to do the second incarnation
which is tapi of three c compliant and
we are we have already pretty much
finished the peer-to-peer now the
centralized peer-to-peer network we have
around more than two hundred thousand
nodes running the peer-to-peer network
which is not the blockchain peer-to-peer
which is the really does the all they
have a lifting we call it the Sandra's
carrier because it does all the
logistics like AT&T Verizon there's all
this data transformation or the video
voice transformation and also on top of
it we're going to build a virtual phones
virtual machines right launch them on
demand so then that's where the the
first one would be the browser the
second one would be some macro websites
running on top on top of those set up
boxes 200 thousands of them right now
running so we'll have some of them being
the talking stations and witches will
start from early January next year and
we expect tiny time they would be
exciting year like 1993 all over again
yeah it is I think for the entire
industry 2020 and 2021 are gonna be
worth paying attention to for sure where
um before I get into the rapid-fire
questions where can people find more
about alas dose and find you on the
Internet I'm a centralized internet
there's like you Lazos org okay and then
there's a cyber e poppin org
and then for developers there's a you
last oh stop Academy mmm so they can
find all the technical specifications
and stuff and yeah gardening courses as
well very cool what about yourself where
can people find you well find me online
but also we I personally if I came to
this country 84 I was not a teenager at
that time I was doing grass Graduate
Studies uh-huh so I try to because this
we are going to build a new internet
next year early next starting early next
year right so the internet definitely is
beyond one person I'm really really
happy and feel relieved the team really
is doing the essential we have these and
track teams all over the world and they
are self-motivated to build this new
world and so me I my row is kind of
getting smaller and smaller diminished
throughout the year so I kind of planned
for myself we promised to the community
because one for four years to build this
a new Internet when we started in August
2017 so I'll be around until at least
August 2021
are you planning an exit are you gonna
leave then well I would think Satoshi
would be a good role model got it very
very interesting rapid-fire questions
what
was the most important company in crypto
other than your own well I think he
theorem is we learned a lot whatwhy
atheria because of the work computer and
also the smart contracts currently we do
have the side chain running the you
theorems are chain running on top of a
las dos we're Payton it's almost all I
mean to older versions of attorney VM of
the smart contracts are running so I
wish that thank give our thanks to you
theorem community very cool what's the
one regulation or law that you would
change or improve if you could either
here or abroad well I think in the u.s.
of course is more of so-called wracked
about legal you know everything is
according to law so many lawyers and so
many things right and crypto is a new
thing and I hope the the Congress folks
should be more open-minded mm-hmm that's
fair what's your most controversial
thought in crypto
what do you believe that everyone else
disagrees with you on I don't believe
block chains can create a ecosystem by
its own okay explain need a second
second-tier because the blockchain for
performance for basically a blockchain
is Bank computer whether you call it war
computer it doesn't really matter when
computer won't solve internet problems
Internet meaning a network of computers
right so anybody trying to build a
ecosystem or Dabbs on one blockchain
it's bound to fail I think it's pretty
controversial what's the most important
book you've ever read why I read like
Taoism bugs teachings or Shakespeare
when I was in college impress girls and
[Music]
you read Shakespeare to impress girls in
college what was your favorite book Wow
all those I read them all for this way
very cool aliens you believe are they
real
I am agnostic either way No
you can't take an agnostic position
either believer you don't believe what
do you think well I don't really believe
you don't believe but I do believe a lot
of people believe that inspired us right
okay so pursue so you think that aliens
probably aren't real but the promise
that they may be out there inspired us
to go look right because let's say going
out of space and a lot of scientific
research that's important but I
personally don't necessarily believe
it's there okay why it's been similar to
the way we grow up a lot of those
stories or teachings and I wouldn't go
explicit and turned out right it's I I
don't believe
oh so you think aliens are like a
religion no no no then the way we grow
up yep right a lot of things we were
taught and but then on the other hand
doesn't really stop us from come to the
u.s. come you know to study to keep on
driving ourselves for sure so do you
think we went to the moon that's lonely
okay all right just checking and then I
always end with you at getting to ask me
one question what one question do you
have for me if you got to meet alien or
Satoshi which one do you pick oh if I
got to me alien or Satoshi uh definitely
alien I actually I actually think we are
much better off not knowing who Satoshi
is I hope we never find out who he she
or they is I think part of the beauty
and strength of Bitcoin is the fact that
we don't know who that person is right
or that group of people and so I don't
want to be the person who ruins it okay
frankly I think you know it's
fascinating to tell for him to tell the
life story
why yes so like if they revealed
themselves then I think there'd be a
tonic really cool things to find out but
I want nothing to do with being the one
to reveal if put in that position and
also like go grab a beer with the alien
right and I have a lot of questions for
the healing it like we start with like
how where are you from and how long did
it take to get here would be would be to
at the top of the list but if you see
the how far the telescope those gigantic
telescope have 30 you know millions
alpha I don't know it may not be
millions of light-years right it'll be
forever it's the travel yeah but if you
if you think about that's just our
galaxy right and there's other galaxies
the one of my favorite things 2019 that
that I read was somebody was able to
identify that there was two galaxies
colliding with each other so like what
happens then I don't really know the
idea that calyx galaxies could collide
is pretty crazy and then they basically
if I remember the article correctly and
I probably don't but I think it was
something like you know two or four
billion years from now our galaxy's
gonna collide with that galaxy
everybody's doomed yeah and it's like
maybe right so I think that we just
don't understand how big the world
really is but but if I had to choose
definitely choosing an alien over
Satoshi's see listen thank you so much
for coming in and doing this I really
appreciate it
and obviously I think a lot of the ideas
and and kind of ethos of what you guys
are doing is shared across the the bit
coin and crypto community in terms of
kind of this decentralized future right
taking back a lot of the the self
sovereignty and and identity etcetera
and ultimately I think that the kind of
that censorship resistance whether it's
in money or in infrastructure is gonna
play a pretty big part in the world
moving forward and so you guys are are
one of many teams that are working on
this and and I think it's pretty
exciting so so thanks for coming in and
explain thank you for the opportunity
and I appreciate ya for sure what to do
to get in the future once you guys get
farther along okay sounds good thanks so
much thank you